عبر هذه الطائره وصل عدد ما يقارب خمسين
من المختصين في طليعه الجسر الجوي السعودي
الذي هي بدا بالذهاب الى تركيا
لاغاثه المتضررين من الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا على حد سواء هؤلاء هم الفريق
السعودي المختص وهم فريق مكون من
من الاطباء والمسعفين والمختصين ايضا
بعمليات الانقاذ الدقيقه وهم سيبداون
اعمالهم مباشره بدءا من الخروج من مطار
اضنه الى الاماكن المتضرره في هذه المدينه
التركيه جراء الزلزال نحن نسعد ان نكون
هنا على الارض قريبين من الحدث وسنكون
قريبا خلال الدقائق القليله القادمه باذن
الله عز وجل المتواجدين في اماكن الاحتياج
نوزع هذه المساعدات باذن الله عز وجل
وسننطلق كذلك الى الداخل السوري في توزيع
هذه المساعدات المساعدات يركز على هذه
المرحله واحتياجاتها وهي مرحله التدخل
الانساني العاجل والطوارئ هنا من مطار
اضنه حيث تتكدس الفرق التطوعيه وحتى
القضيه القادمه من خارج تركيا لمساعده
تركيا على
مساعده متضرري الزلزال هنا فريق سعودي في
الجانب الاخر بينما وصل قبل قليل هنا ايضا
فريق من البرتغال الاغاثي يستعد للخروج من
هذا المطار ويبدو انه مكث طويلا حتى هذه
اللحظه بالاضافه الى الجانب الاخر حيث
يتواجد فريق من التايوان وهي وهو فريق
انقاذي كبير يبدو انه وصل منذ فتره طويله
الا انه حتى الان لم يغادر هذا المطار هذه
هي الحركه في مطار اضنه حيث الكثير من
الفرق التطوعيه في كل في كل زاويه الفرق
الانقاديه من كل دول العالم تاتي الى هذا
المطار لتبدا
العمليات الانقاديه خارج المطار في مدينه
اضنه او حتى في المناطق المحيطه المنكوبه
في تركيا